now if the last two weeks have taught us
anything
it's that the left is obsessed with
teaching children about sexual and
gender identity
in private schools it's dubbed a queer
inclusive curriculum
it's being secretly rolled out without
parents knowledge by the national
association of independent schools
now here's part of a workshop that's
just now coming to light
they start them real young
with the younger children starting in
pre-k
we talk about their bodies about the
parts that they were born with
about penises and vaginas and whether
that makes somebody a boy or a girl
but also their feelings
what do they feel like inside do they
feel like a boy or a girl what does
their head say does their head and their
heart and their body match up
how dare they well what on earth
thanks to breitbart by the way for
publishing this
now this isn't going to go over well
remember what happened when moms and
dads across america by the way of both
political persuasions saw what happened
in florida where disney opposed governor
desantis's parental rights and education
bill
the law that disney finds so horrifying
merely prohibits sexually explicit
construction for five to eight-year-olds
including stuff like this
second grade we move on explicitly to
gender identity and talk about it again
in terms of your head and your heart and
your body parts matching up and does
that work for you
what happens if it doesn't and the kids
draw wonderful self portraits again
but dealing with all aspects of their
identity including specifically their
gender identity
now gone are the days when they're just
teaching about human reproduction now by
fifth grade they're taught about sexual
expression and moran identity
gender expression is what you share with
the world it's something that you can
change from day to day it's completely
up to you
sexual orientation
is who you are emotionally and
physically attracted to we talk about
gender identity specifically with the
gender unicorn this time talking about
things as a continuum
the gender unicorn
now by the time the kids get into middle
school
they're then bombarded by efforts to
undo any semblance of traditional values
that their parents might have taught
them
teachers and administrators often with
very fun personalities by the way are
eager to share their own experiences
with sexual and gender identity like
this assistant principal in burlington
vermont
students call me ap ellis
since i don't use gendered pronouns in
my name i personally identify both as
gender non-conforming and gender
non-binary in that i do not feel
just female or male but i feel
a mix of of that within myself
then this complaint about misgendering
as a trans person it does get really
tiresome in conversations where i'm
being misgendered and i'm carrying the
discomfort of another adult for their
mistake
and
and sort of have to take the burden of
the discomfort of that uh and again i
think kids do a really miraculous job of
not doing that
okay i got it children
who don't misgender
are miraculous because they haven't been
ruined by their more traditional parents
i understand
now remember these schools are educating
the next generation of educators gotta
get them on board gotta get them on
message
i'm gonna open the door for our student
panelists to weigh in here i feel
respected with my gender but i
definitely think that we should talk
about it more outside
and like more
throughout different classes during the
day i'm in middle school and i have a
younger sibling in fourth grade
and
not 100 sure what their pronouns are
wow why are these people so invested in
pushing these concepts
on children of any age
now they seem to forget that parents pay
the salaries of these teachers and the
school board members
and now it's up to parents to get
informed and speak up
some already are families across america
are swearing off disney
they seem to think are pleasing everyone
when if they actually spoke to the
people in the park they'd find out
they're not it is the parents jobs
to teach their children
on the society of the norms
and of this and of the norms of their
household i think they need to stay out
of politics
but mouseland isn't backing down they're
more afraid of offending radical
activists than they are the families who
buy those really really expensive park
hopper passes
oh that's fine we're going to see how
that all works out for disney
marketing sneakers or those goofy mouse
ears to kids that's one thing
but marketing complicated topics of
sexuality and gender
that's grooming
oh wait i'm sorry i'm sorry joy reid
doesn't like that language sorry
conservative political operatives have
figured out what riles up their base the
fake threat that progressives are trying
to indoctrinate their children to groom
them to become gay or trans these terms
indoctrination grooming predator
accusing innocent people of being
pedophiles or being soft on pedophiles
it is all so a very specific trigger for
a group that is sinking its teeth into
our political discourse
mix metaphors aside whatever term you
want to use to describe what they're
doing
it's having a dramatic effect on our
young people
how else do you explain that today 20 of
gen z identifies as lgbtq plus
which is double that of millennials five
times more than gen x
and ten times those who identify as such
among the baby boomers they're boring
well we all know what influence peddling
looks like in the political context
right we see it we know it it's why
china paid hunter biden all that money
and why the clinton foundation got all
those big contributions from places like
saudi arabia and qatar well what's
happening in our schools
is sexual influence peddling
and if you want to protect your kids
you have to get up to speed on what your
kids are being subjected to at school
as a preschool teacher a drag king and
as a member of the lgbtq community
how
do i feel about the new legislations
for like the don't say gay bill i don't
care what the government tells me to do
i am going to do what i think is best
for the health
and safety of my kids
well first we love all people whatever
you believe whatever you are we love all
of humankind
but i will say this the left has gotten
itself so tangled up
with some of the more radical confused
elements in society that they are now
offering absurdly contorted defenses of
all this adopting the slogan
saves the children which of course
sounds
perfectly noble innocent enough on its
face but as associate press reports has
actually become a dog whistle to q anon
supporters this is q anon all the way
down
republicans are repurposing old smears
to take democrats as part of a shadowy
cabal of child sex abusers
what is he talking about no one's saying
anything i don't know anyone is saying
any of that what we are saying is that
children should go to school to learn
how to read and write to learn math and
science and wonderful history
and we are saying that their innocence
is worth protecting
marinating our kids and lessons on
gender inclusivity and sexual expression
it's not going to help them succeed in
its ever competitive world we live in
and it goes without saying that everyone
and i mean everyone should feel safe in
school bullying should never be
tolerated
but the bullies today are often those
who refuse to respect parental
boundaries
those who seek to destroy a kid's
innocence in the name of tolerance
parents we've spoken with have had
enough
and they're mobilizing
and to help them we have created the
ingram angle parent portal
it's a place for you to share what your
children are seeing and hearing in the
classroom we'll hear the good and the
not so good
email us
at ingramangle
fox.com
send us examples of some of the lessons
that your kids are
learning or seeing or hearing
and be sure to include the school
district the city and the state and keep
all comments respectful
tolerance demands that the dignity of
all people be respected including the
dignity and innocence of our children
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else